when Wi-Fi works well it is awesome but
it is even more annoying when you cannot
get a good connection Wi-Fi extenders
can fill in that spot your house or
business but it is often a mystery how
these devices performance wizardry so
here's how the Wi-Fi centers work and
some tips when buying one
[Music]
welcome to Hari Saba's inner workings
that why factors are actually quite
simple what if X Turner's are you should
plug into a wall outlet and have two
antennas which receive replicate and
rebroadcast a new Wi-Fi signal it's
basically another router your router
takes an eternity able and projects out
Wi-Fi the Wi-Fi extender takes in Wi-Fi
generally but can also take an Ethernet
then projects our Wi-Fi just like a
Wi-Fi router due to the big engine is
that most of these Y factors possess
they can often capture the Wi-Fi signal
much better than any of your laptops or
devices good as a result Wi-Fi extenders
are able to receive a better signal even
in dead spots and project a even more
superior signal out your devices so in a
nutshell that's basically what Wi-Fi
ex-nurse do and how they provide a much
stronger signal for you now how is a
Wi-Fi extender different from a Wi-Fi
booster well a Wi-Fi booster is
essentially supposed to be a stronger
router Wi-Fi boosters are designed to be
directly plugged into a router and using
larger more powerful antennas they're
able to project the Wi-Fi interfer the
range Wi-Fi boosters make the overall
range of for a Wi-Fi bigger while a
Wi-Fi extenders add to the range of your
main router now if your router is not
that great then buying a Wi-Fi booster
can help it tremendously however if your
router is already quite decent then a
Wi-Fi booster won't go help that much in
that case you're probably better off
going with a Wi-Fi extender but what you
look out for when buying one as for tip
number one don't buy a Wi-Fi extender
radically stronger during internet
connection because this will be more
expensive but we'll help you at all
for example let's say your internet
connection is 50 Mbps and the max video
provider offers 100 Mbps then don't go
out and buy a Wi-Fi extender that is
1200 Mbps a Wi-Fi extender cannot make
your internet connection itself any
faster
a guru Mbps extender will be more than
sufficient in that scenario as for tip
number 2 if you're looking at buying a
wide effects tuner with ethernet ports
that make sure that the wife extra not
only has enough Ethernet ports but today
Ethernet ports are the right type you
don't want to eat an airport slim your
connection for example if you have 50
Mbps internet but the Ethernet port on a
Wi-Fi extender is slant 10 or 10 Mbps
and you will never get any faster than 2
Mbps from that however this is much less
of an issue nowadays with pretty much
all wife externals coming with a LAN 100
port or a 100 Mbps Ethernet connection
however where you should be careful is
if you have gigabit fiber internet and
make sure that your wife text alert has
a gigabit port because if it doesn't
you're going to be losing out big-ass /
tip number 3 make sure the frequency
bands of your Wi-Fi extender are the
same as your Wi-Fi router there are two
different Wi-Fi bands which are 2.4
gigahertz and five-year Hertz they both
have their own set of strong suits for
example a five-year connection is
usually better for short distances but
faster speed and 2.40 hers is better for
long distance and just stable speed some
wife actors only come with the 2.4
gigahertz connection which says single
band repeater so make sure to avoid
these instead get a dual band repeater
which will work at 2.4 gigahertz and
popular whenever using it though make
sure that it is set it's the same as the
router for best results and one more
bonus tip after you buy your Wi-Fi
extender is that make sure you place it
in the right spot you want to Midway in
between where you would like to extend a
Wi-Fi - and your router
fortunately modern extenders
come on ABS that age you've been finding
the optimum location so make sure to
take advantage of these in order to
maximize your Wi-Fi speeds but that's
pretty much it as to how Wi-Fi xn does
work and some tips on buying one
did I miss something really crucial but
why FAQ centers and what topic would you
like to me to cover next make sure that
post doors down below also if you guys
found this video helpful then make sure
drop a like and consider subscribing if
you'd like to see more videos just like
this one but until then I'm Hari I'll
see you guys on the next one
[Music]